j'ai tellement je suis tellement content
d'être là franchement hier soir à 21h
j'apprends j'apprends que je râle
émission c'est un peu comme si votre
copain il y tient demain tu prends ma
ferrari donc ça tu étais content et deux
heures après te rappelle le mec qui te
dis oui je te prête la ferrari mais faut
que tu pas de mes mômes derrière c'est
la raison pour laquelle c'est la raison
pour laquelle dans la tête j'ai dit aux
arts du paf grill
hier soir vers 22 heures il a invité
julien castaldi comme chroniqueur ça va
mon pays mais je ne peux pas rêver mieux
mon père tpm paix le summum dans mon
père puis tpn fuite avec les choses dans
la fusée mois ah ben voilà voilà
là je me sens là je me sens un animateur
la voilà c'est moi à gauche regardez
comment hugo les le petit ronaldo
franchement il faut qu'ils mangent à peu
le garçon quand même là mais c'est
musclé mais non mais les minions à
milady non moi je répondais moi je
n'attendais une photo de ouf et les
tablettes là les diabètes cdo ce que
c'est c'est pour ça alors honnêtement
c'est pas si c'est des abdos ou si c'est
parce qu'il est unique tout une itw into
my skin comme en mer benjamin oui
franchement c'est triste c'est un fils
comme ça veut imiter son père c'est
comme si votre fils voulait faire de la
télé c'est un cadeau
alors franchement alors excusé chaubon
pire c'est tu fait pire sans les photos
montrent elles ou à écouter si vous avez
le temps d'aller on va chercher ce sens
mais mais mais réseau il ya peut-être
deux ou trois photos je suis ça fait
très mal mais bon voilà je suis sap et
didon c'est quoi ça la femme en 2018
c'est pas c'est pas comme ça c'est plus
naturel je préfère le style naturel pour
toi alors mais alors je réponds à maxime
qui s'y connaît sur elle
[Applaudissements]
ça va possible cette photo où il fait le
lancement après la pub tu décroches
tamer toile à la confiance chez ma mère
et le petit fait une demi chronique et
d'une demi info mais il fallait bien je
sais pas je ne vaux je vais je vais je
vais réfléchir ok moi pour l'instant je
suis pas pour piloter sud aquitaine on
me pousse dehors
votre ballon c est ce que vous voulez
chez vous voilà s'il vous plaît c'est
mon rêve aux eaux
c'est vrai ça c'est vraiment moi est ce
que vous voulez chez vous que même fils
donc reprennent après la pub il vous
plait non mais je me sens un peu de télé
comme ça je me casse la figure et que je
me pète quelque chose je dis juste s'il
te plaît mais j'ai compris est-ce que
chez vous voulez vous est envoyé quoi
achetable quoi je t'ai que julien je
viens te plaindre
voilà qui sent encore benjamin bellecour
papa pas trop j'ai compris tu aurais on
verra ce que tu fais pour l'instant on
n'en on enchaîne avec l'autre et on lui
donne ça y est ce que oui ou non julien
reprend après la pub à ma place est ce
que vous voulez en gros que je m'en
aille non ça veut pas dire ça papa ça
merci il me laisse ma chambre le front
comme je le veux mais à son fils alors
on le dit pas on l'a vu à les y renvoyer
mon à vue
[Applaudissements]
mon père car si tu penses même à son
salaire la sécu on en est où papa de dix
mois a subi la mission oui mais nazis
j'arrive à deux mois qu'est ce que ça
c'est qu est ce que tu trouves pas le
chiffre vraiment exorbitants et
totalement mettant je pense que le club
devrait payer les opérations de des
grands joueurs de foot avec un salaire
pareil le problème c'est que je ne sais
pas ce qu on fait juste après c'est quoi
la séquence que je devais beaucoup
elles devraient être présentes à la
cérémonie des césar qui a lieu donc ce
vendredi soir belle va donc monter sur
scène et faire une petite récompense qui
est donc le césar bonnet c'est assez
génial c'était parfait
tel père tel fils caméra
[Applaudissements]